[Music]
[Applause]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was the hardest thing
i've ever had to do was
charlie sheen wrote get clean
jennifer lopez wrote leave my husband
mitt romney wrote fire my chefs butler
chauffeur
that works
here's the next one i taught my dog how
to paul rudd wrote bring me the
newspaper
sofia vergara wrote roll over and play
dead
nick was cage wrote pick the movies i
should star in
what i enjoy most about american idol is
emma roberts wrote hearing fresh young
talent
danny mcbride wrote watching young
people chasing their dreams
vladimir putin wrote declaring myself
the winner
he was very good oh he's very good yeah
i hate it when the paparazzi
brad pitt wrote bother me and my
children
antonio banderas wrote invade my
family's privacy
conan o'brien wrote tell me i'm blocking
their view of jim belushi
very disappointed in all of you
for enjoying that one my favorite pig
out food is
ricky gervais wrote pizza
john krasinski wrote cheeseburgers
chris christie wrote people who've just
eaten pizza
he needs people now
i found the historical details accurate
in the movie tom brokaw wrote saving
private ryan
maya angelou wrote the help
larry king wrote ice age
technical consultant on that movie
when someone hacks my phone and finds
nude photos i olivia munn wrote laugh it
off
christina hendricks wrote don't give
their story any attention
andy richter wrote no the eyes of the
world are going to be feasting on some
andy candy
you don't you don't see my face in any
of those no i know no no you can't tell
big deal and finally when i get married
i want the cake to be
elle fanning wrote traditional but
festive
justin bieber wrote a celebration of
music and romance
snooki's fiance wrote made of penicillin
[Applause]